foreign
Cincinnati hi Christina how are you
I'm doing well Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up
uh so quick question I am expecting to
be out of baby step three here in the
next few months
um and I don't know if I should be in
baby step 3B or if I should start baby
steps four and five
and also if I'm to start the investing
baby step if I use my dad who's a
financial advisor who is well known in
the town or if I use one of your smart
master Pros
okay how old are you
26. okay
why would you not use your dad
I I've been hard set on following your
ways your baby steps and just doing the
Dave way and
he won't go along with that
she goes for the most part I mean he
doesn't like selling the baby steps
he still uses credit cards but like he
pays them off now your financial advisor
doesn't control your credit cards
right your financial advisor handles
your Roth IRAs
Christina does your dad give you advice
on a lot of things that you don't ask
him for advice on
no
why are you it seems like the question
behind your question is that you don't
necessarily want your dad dealing with
your money is that right or wrong
I don't have an issue with my dad
dealing with my money I've been waiting
to go over to his house to have him
really like
you can't take my budget really so
I don't know I it's something that I've
been contemplating like do I go with my
dad or do I use one of your smart
investors just because like I'm very
into if your dad will allow you to make
your own decisions and will do what you
tell him to do with your money
you would use your dad
okay unless she's not a person of
Integrity or you have some kind of a
relational violation with him but if he
has control freak issues or if he's got
boundary issues and he's going to tell
you what you have to do and if you don't
do it the way he wants he's going to use
his dad voice then then you would not
use your dad or if he's going to move
you in funds and just let you know hey I
went ahead and moved all this for you
because I saw something in the market
then that a Trader like a smartvestor
pro would normally call me and say hey
I'm thinking about doing this I want to
recommend this what do you think
um
that he will let you be an adult and
make your own decisions and he follows
the fine he makes suggestions and then
does what you tell him to do with your
money after you've had his teaching and
his advice and his suggestions then
that's a healthy reasonable boundary
situation you have no relational
breakdown with him otherwise then I
would use your dad
that's how I would do it no question
about it if he is if he's saying listen
you need to buy this whole life life
insurance policy and you say no I don't
use whole life life insurance and he has
a fit and acts like you're 14 years old
then you don't need to use your dad yeah
but but I don't hear that here
I I kind of think we're being tested to
see if we send everybody to smartvest
approach no matter what but
um I don't I mean it's it's there's
nothing wrong as long as you're a
financial advisor is not confused about
who owns the money but I mean financial
advisors cfp sometimes means Certified
Financial Pharisee sometimes it means
certified financial planner and they
actually will teach you things uh but
some people in that business they get
like a doc syndrome and they're like I'm
God now and you need to listen to me
that's right uh whether it's your dad or
not right and so that's why we always
tell folks you're looking for someone
and while we vet our smart investor Pros
you're looking for someone that has the
heart of a teacher not the heart of a
Salesman or a control freak because the
first time one of these characters in
the financial world or in the legal
World tells me what I have to do with my
life instead of suggests that here's a
wise course of action then our that we
just were done yeah I'm done yeah and I
my my smart investor Pro is an old
friend and I said hey I don't I don't
you don't have to do your Spiel I just
want you to do I want you to do this and
he said I don't do that I teach and it
was a it was a this is like I'm not
going to do business with you if you
want me just to run your life my job is
to teach you what's going on with your
money and and so I really appreciate the
pushback it was good no that's because
he doesn't do it the other way that's
and there really is only two types of
people in the financial world and that
that's the two types so yeah I mean it's
perfectly fine to do that but what I
often run into is is there's a
you know her like you know Dad pouch or
something like that and I'm like we
ain't part of my advice you know and so
uh you know they follow Dave and that
somehow is a judgment or an indictment
against you Dad and I don't ah man you
use credit card points I don't want to
deal with I don't I don't want to deal
with that that world I'm not gonna argue
with you about it I'm just gonna do what
I'm gonna do exactly